Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking. Question,
I'm a cybernetic organism living.
This episode is brought to you by 99
designs when your business needs a logo,
website, business card,
thumbnail, or any other design.
I recommend checking out 99 designs.
I use them myself.
I've used them for many years.
I used them to create book cover
prototypes for the four hour body,
which went on to becoming number
one New York Times bestseller.
I've also used them for
banner ads, illustrations, and
much more. With 99 designs.
You get a variety of original designs
from designers around the world.
Give your feedback and then pick your
favorite. Your happiness is guaranteed.
So check out some of my competitions in
designs and some of your competitions
and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss.
Show listeners@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash Tim and
right now you can get
a free $99 upgrade on your first design,
so check it out.
99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim.
Yeah.
This episode is brought to you by
gymnastic bodies.com this is the training
system that I am most obsessed with
at the moment and I don't get paid any
commissions or anything like that.
You may have heard coach summer on
the podcast who designed the program,
former national team coach
for men's gymnastics.
I am not easily impressed and I've
just been completely blown away by the
sophistication of his programming
and the elegance of his programming.
I've been using gymnastic bodies for
just a few months now and I feel more
flexible, stronger, and
younger than I have in years.
And it sounds cheesy to hear
myself say that, but it's true.
That's the hardest part to
believe and you can check it out.
Gymnastic bodies.com forward slash
Tim if you go to that landing page,
gymnastic bodies.com forward slash Tim
you can take a look at the fundamentals
course, which I'll help you diagnose
your weakest points, areas to improve,
et cetera.
And I highly encourage you take a look
at this bodyweight training system.
It is incredible.
Gymnastic bodies.com forward slash Tim.
Hello boys and girls.
Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where
it is usually my job to interview world
class performers and tease out the
habits, routines, tools, tricks,
et cetera that you can use.
This episode is a role reversal.
I went to New York City and I sat down
with Stephen Dubner freakonomics fame and
I was grilled.
I was hit with all sorts of questions
I had never heard before and we had a
blast doing it.
We had so much fun and their team did an
incredible job with post production and
editing.
I wanted to share it with all of you and
you can of course find Steven and his
team and his coauthor@freakonomics.com
at freakonomics on Twitter and
freakonomics radio in the podcasts
sphere and without further preamble,
please enjoy my wide ranging sometimes
very odd conversation with Stephen
Dubner.
If you don't try hard,
no matter how much talent you have,
there's always going to be someone else
who has a similar amount of talent who
out works you and therefore
outperforms you. It's very easy.
I think in a digital age easier than
ever to confuse being busy with being
productive and they're just
not the same thing. Well,
what if I did something
with some more passion?
What if I found something to
be a deeper interest to me?
I thought maybe I should give it a go
and see if it was actually possible to
improve.
Let's start with in 60 seconds or less
what you actually do in a given day if
you have such a thing as a given day.
I would say interviewing experts,
tracking down eccentric Weirdos who are
really good at one thing or another.
Formulating a plan for some
type of experiment involving
their observations are
findings and then recording it.
That is what I do most days.
That is Tim Ferriss.
He is,
hmm.
What is he exactly?
I am a human Guinea pig and
professional dilettante.
For our final self improvement episode,
a man whose entire life and career are
one big pile of self improvement of
accelerated self improvement as
evidenced by his book titles.
The four hour work week,
the four hour chef,
the four hour body,
Tim Ferris is in fact such a poster boy
for self improvement that you might be
as I first was a bit suspicious,
I'd seen your face and I knew that you
were the four hour blank guy and of
course I assumed that you were a
total charlatan. Of course. Right?
Cause that's how could you not with a
title like that Tim Ferris Charlatan or
self improvement wizard,
you'll be the judge as we cover
everything from his humble beginnings,
I mean very much the runt of the litter
in school and some rough patches.
So I've had extended periods of depression
that I've become better at mitigating
over time to his good
fortune in startup investing.
Facebook also did very well to the
reason that millions of people do every
single thing the Tim
Ferriss tells him to do.
So the objective is to provide you with
tools and principles for 10 x in your
hourly output.
Is there anyone here who isn't interested
in 10 exing their hourly output?
No,
I didn't think so.
From wny c studios,
this is freakonomics radio.
The podcast that explores the
hidden side of everything.
Here's your host,
Steven Dubner.
Tim Ferris
recently stopped by our studio with a
head full of ideas and as you'll hear,
a belly full of sardines.
I suppose my professional life can be
split into writing books that all sound
like infomercial products,
most notably the four hour
workweek and then tech investing.
So if you had to pick a noun or maybe two
to describe what you think of yourself
as, what is the noun?
Noun will be teacher.
I don't view myself as a
writer first and foremost.
I always thought I was
gonna end up teaching ninth
grade specifically because I
had a lot of really formative influences.
I think at that fork in the road or a lot
of crucial decisions are made by young
folks, but I view my job as testing
many, many different things,
performing experiments and then
providing the cliff notes to people.
As a teacher.
Not long ago you also started a podcast
which is called the Tim Ferriss show.
Now why did you want to go
and do a thing like that?
Cause we all know that
podcasting is not where it's at.
It was intended to be a break between
large book projects and I have this nasty
habit of writing along books.
So the four hour chef was 670 pages.
So weird in the best way. They're
not narrative from beginning to end.
Even when they kind of feel a little bit
like those self help books with boxes
and charts, you are just zany in a way
that reminds me, I'll be honest with you,
of one person where anyone else,
which was my mom,
my mom was this kind of Brooklyn girl who
ended up in upstate New York trying to
be a pioneer woman and raise
eight kids and she did it.
She had to figure out all this stuff and
that's what strikes me is what you have
this intense either curiosity or need or
something to figure out stuff and then
tell other people about it, which
is, you know, generous of you.
Where does that come from?
Why?
Why are you not satisfied with
just being like everybody else?
I think the answer's
twofold. So, number one,
my mom always encouraged me to
march to my own drummer. So that
how,
how'd you do that?
She exposed. Me and my brother. I have
one sibling, a younger brother, too many,
many different environments. My parents
didn't have much money growing up,
but they always had a budget for books.
And my mom would take us to
experience things firsthand,
like go to the beach and take leftover
chicken bones and tie them to strings and
fish for crabs, which we threw back.
But the, the list just went on and on.
And if we grasped on anything and became
really passionate, then she would, uh,
and,
and my father as well.